le 14 juin 2017 coup de tonnerre marcel
et jacqueline jacob le grand oncle et la
grand tante du garçonnet sont
interpellés et mis en examen
le couple n'avait jamais été inquiété
par la justice
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que nous
avons avancé significativement est-ce
que ça permettra de découvrir la vérité
dans ce dossier je n'en sais rien deux
semaines plus tard un autre personnage
cette fois bien connu du dossier et
arrêtez les enquêteurs s'interrogent sur
le rôle de muriel bolle dans
l'enlèvement de grégory après cinq
semaines de détention et une grève de la
faim et il est placé sous contrôle
judiciaire à saint-honoré-les-bains dans
la nièvre et vit dans un beau cadre elle
n'a pas de vis-à-vis est là les prêts en
face à intel voit des valeurs tout le
monde sait rouler donc où elle voit des
charolaises me parle de sa fille trente
trois ans après la mort du garçonnet
c'est le clan laroche qui est ciblé pour
les enquêteurs l'hypothèse d'un acte
collectif se dessine mais pour la
défense le dossier est vide au maintien
des gens sous contrôle judiciaire comme
trois ans après des faits des faits qui
sont contestés et le dossier de
l'accusation s'effondre au fur et à
mesure des investigations quelques mois
plus tard le dossier n'a toujours pas
livré sa vérité faute de preuves et
d'aveux les contrôles judiciaires des
époux jacob et de muriel bolle sont
allégées tous rentrent chez eux dans les
vosges c'est un grand soulagement c'est
une grande joie
c'est quelqu'un qui était en train
véritablement physiquement et
psychologiquement de dépérir
elle va enfin pouvoir renouer le fil de
sa vie elle a éclaté en sanglots et elle
s'est confondu en remerciements il y a
un an
ressurgissent est l'une des affaires
criminelles les plus médiatiques de
france
mais aujourd'hui le dossier c'est peut
être définitivement refermé